Film Courage: Well, it’s 2016 (at the taping
of this interview), August 2016.
A summer day in Los Angeles…[laughs]…I
don’t know why I feel the need to say this…but
we met with you the first time in 2012.
That was 4 years ago.
So since that time, a lot has happened in
your life.
You’ve been part of many projects, different
things.
Have you become more idealistic about filmmaking,
less so, more realistic about what is needed
to work in Hollywood?
Daniel Stamm: That is a great question.
Have you talked to people who get more idealistic
as their career goes on?
I want to talk to those people.
Film Courage: [Laughs].
Daniel Stamm: It’s an interesting question
because after we last met I think I was just
in preparation for a movie.
I think I was about to shoot 13 SINS, my last
feature film.
I haven’t made a feature film since then.
And it’s interesting if I’ve gotten more
idealistic or less so.
I think it’s a mixture of both because I
am very proud of 13 SINS but it never went
anywhere.
It made nine thousand dollars at the box office.
It came after THE LAST EXORCISM which was,
you can discuss whether it was a better film
or a worse film or whatever, but box office
wise it was a 70 million dollar success going
to a nine thousand dollar complete failure
at the box office, right?
Which I would claim I have nothing to do with
either.
Not with that success or with that failure
because of marketing and how much money is
being pumped into stuff.
THE LAST EXORCISM has a marketing budget of
24 million dollars.
So it’s easier to get people to see it and
make that kind of money.
13 SINS didn’t have a single dollar of marketing
budget and that depended on (without pointing
any fingers) who buys your movie.
And in that case the company that bought the
movie just before 13 SINS was going to be
released had a huge flop with a movie that
they had big hopes for and had just done a
big marketing campaign for.
They didn’t have the capacity to get 13
SINS released theatrically.
So suddenly you are a VOD movie, which is
not a problem but it is a difference of if
you see the chart of your career, the way
it’s perceived.
You’re going from the world wide theatrical
movie to the VOD movie in America, which means
nowhere else is it going to go theatrical.
So suddenly you have a movie that is basically
disappearing which has nothing to do with
its quality.
This success did not necessarily have anything
to do with its quality.
But you know you are being held accountable.
So I then kind of had to see where to get
the next paycheck from because suddenly I
am not this filmmaker anymore because Hollywood
is…you are worth as much as your last project
made at the box office basically.
So I was worth this much after THE LAST EXORCISM
[gestures up high with his hand] and I was
worth this much with 13 SINS [gestures down
low with his hands].
It’s a real problem to get yourself out
of.
So the answer is TV.
And I was always like “I don’t want to
do TV.
I don’t want to do TV.”
But I had to get my rent check from somewhere
and I think the landscape really changed.
Maybe I’m just telling myself that because
I’m doing TV but I think a lot has happened
since we last spoke in terms of with TRUE
DETECTIVE, with GAME OF THRONES, that some
of the best storytelling today is being done
in TV.
So it’s not actually as bleak a world has
I would have thought back then….QUESTION
FOR THE VIEWERS: How much blame should be
on a director if their movie bombs at the
box office?